Right. Hello everyone. Uh today I will
present meta adaptive context
engineering or meta AC for short which
is a new framework designed to optimize
AI agents beyond single dimension
approaches. We will explore how
orchestrating multiple adaptation
strategies can overcome the limitations
of existing context engineering methods.
Now a little introduction about myself.
Uh so I'm Alberto Romero. I'm the
co-founder and CEO at jointly. And for
context at jointly we build the main
specialized agents for regulated
industries where policy adherance
constraints are particularly strict.
Most of our research work is in the area
of selfoptimizing agent architectures uh
using systematic approaches.
Now about myself, I have spent uh 20
plus years at the intersection of AI and
data. Uh some of my recent experience
includes being the CTO and co-founder of
human AI uh think MLbased risk
prediction for mobility which was
acquired by AON in 2023 and in my
previous role I headed up city bank's
genai engineering team.
Now here's our agenda for today. Um
we'll begin with the motivation and
problems that current systems face. Then
we'll review the AC framework and its
limitations.
Um after surveying recent research uh
insights, we'll introduce the meta AC
approach. We'll discuss its architecture
and strategy toolbox, show some results
um and finish with future directions on
challenges.
Now the agentic context engineering
framework or AC for short uh for which
you've got the paper link uh on the
slide there. So it's it's very popular
framework um and the paper um came out a
few months ago. Um basically organizes a
patient into three roles. First of all
there's a generator that produces
reasoning paths. Then there's a
reflector that extracts lessons. And
finally, there is a curator that
synthesizes these lessons into
incremental updates.
AC uses incremental delta updates and a
grow and refine mechanism to prevent
context collapse and maintain relevance.
Now, most importantly, it can improve
without label data by learning directly
from execution feedback.
Now so AC has been um quite successful
and has achieved substantial gains
across some of the most popular HM
benchmarks like Upworld or finer uh
almost an 11% compared to previous
state-of-the-art approaches such as Japa
or DC.
Um and it's also achieved an 8.6%
um gain on financial reasoning tasks.
Um there are four fundamental
limitations um for AC that I'm going to
reflect on and um just discuss on the
next slide. Um and those form the basis
for um for meta AC basically.
Now as I was saying um despite it
strength AC has got four critical
failure modes. First it is highly
dependent on the reflector. Um so when
reflection fails the context becomes
noisy and even harmful.
Uh secondly there's feedback
brittleleness which means that when
ground truth signals are weak or absent
AC may reinforce incorrect behaviors.
Third, the the task complexity blindness
um which leads to treat simple and
complex tasks the same which can be a
waste of resource uh and also a miss of
opportunities um for optimization
and then finally um AC optimizes only
the context dimension so ignores compute
memory and parameter updates.
Now the 24 and 25 research landscape
offers um four key insights in my views.
First of all uh verification me
mechanisms uh like self evaluation,
multimodel consensus and execution
checks are really important for
robustness of any solution.
Secondly, uh adaptive compute allocation
shows that small models can outperform
much larger ones by selectively
increasing inference steps.
The third one is that structured memory
architectures outperform linear context
context accumulation by organizing facts
as graphs or multi-randular memories.
Then finally, test time training bridges
inference and learning uh and enables
temporary parameter updates to yield
large accuracy gains.
So these advances suggest that we need a
hybrid multi-dimensional system.
Now, MetaC um addresses AC's limitation
by adding a meta controller that learns
to orchestrate multiple adaptation
strategies based on a task's complexity,
uncertainty, verifiability,
and also resource constraints. So
instead of applying the same procedure
to every problem, Metaac profiles each
task and allocates the right combination
of strategies across context, compute,
verification, memory and parameter
dimensions.
Um so this adaptive uh learned
coordination is what enables it to
outperform single dimension methods.
Now the the meta framework consists of
four layers. So getting into the
architecture
um the first layer is the task profiling
one which assesses complexity
uncertainty verifiability and resource
budgets.
Then there is a lightweight meta
controller that selects and allocates
adaptation strategies accordingly.
The next layer down is a strategy
execution one and the carries out the
reflection, adaptive compute,
hierarchical verification,
structure memory retrieval and selective
uh test time training. And then finally
uh there's a feedback aggregation layer
that collects the outcomes and updates
the meta controllers policy through
metalarning.
So this layer design allows the system
to learn from its experience and uh
continuously refine its decision making.
Now in terms of the task profiling um
there are four key dimensions that are
being assessed. The first one is uh
semantic complexity. So this is
basically an embedding based similarity
to uh known dash distributions that gets
produced.
Uh second one is uncertainty
quantification.
Uh think of it as a relative softmax uh
scoring that predicts model confidence.
The third one is verifiability
assessment. So whether we can execute
and validate the output.
And then the fourth one is resource
availability. So we take into
consideration the context window, the
compute budget and even other
constraints such as time.
So the output of this layer of the task
profiling layer is a 32dimensional task
embedding which is what fits as input
into the meta controller.
Now in terms of the strategy toolbox um
meta draws from six strategies.
First one is minimal context which uses
concise prompts for simple tasks.
Um then we use AC reflection uh which
retains the generator reflector curator
loop for incremental knowledge
accumulation um as established by uh
standard AC.
Then we also use adaptive compute which
scales the number of reasoning steps or
samples based on the task difficulty.
We also use hierarchical verification
that combines self-evaluation multimodal
consensus and execution checks.
uh adaptive memory uh that retrieves
relevant information from structured
multi granular memories and then finally
we use selective test time training
which applies temporary parameter
updates such as lower adapters for high
stakes tasks.
So the meta controller learns to combine
these tools effectively over time.
Now the um reward formula um upon which
the the learning strategy is selected
accounts for the following components.
Um the first one is the correctness of
an action or prediction which is
accuracy.
Then we also have the penalty associated
um with resources used or negative
outcomes. So one minus cost and then is
the trustworthiness of the models which
is self-expressed certainty.
So the confidence calibration basically
uh with weighted importance determined
by the hyperparameters alpha, beta and
gamma.
In terms of the uh metalarning loop um
we have four sources of feedback
collection. Uh first of all is task
outcomes. The success failure or
correctness um of the task. Then we've
got the strategy performance. So what is
the individual contribution of each
strategy to the overall performance of
the task?
Then we also have efficiency metrics
such as the compute, latency, memory.
And then finally we've got confidence
calibration. So where predictions are
accurate.
Um so moving on to um how we go on about
uh solving the uh the limitations from
AC. The first one was the weak reflector
problem. So AC's issue is that there is
a a 50 to 60% performance drop when
reflector quality degrades. Um with beta
AC we introduce um uh three things
basically. So first of all is quality
gates. Um so it's a learned classifier
that blocks harmful deltas and secondly
there's a multi- signal reflector uh or
reflection which basically um is an
ensemble of specialist models uh when
there is a level of uncertainty.
Uh and then the third one is adaptive
strategy allocation. So the meta
controller learns when reflection fails
and then it roots to verification or
test time compute instead.
Um so we can expect to maintain an 80%
plus performance even when the uh
reflector degrades around 30%.
Now the the second um limitation we had
was um the feedback quality
brittleleness.
So what we observe with AC is that there
can be significant degradation without
reliable ground truth signals.
Uh with beta AC we introduce a
hierarchical verification cascade um
where we can expect a 50 to 60%
reduction in errors from poor feedback
and that's through three tiers. The
first tier is self verification which is
just fast filter. We just accept if the
confidence level is over a certain
value. Second tier is a multimodel
consensus. So we leverage a diverse
range of models such as GBT4, claude and
dips and we do confidence weighted
voting. And then the tier three is
execution based verification
uh where we leverage code sandbox APA
API validation and schema compliance.
Um the the third um limitation we had
was uh task complexity mismatch. Um so
in a sense the fact that AC uses uniform
processing um also for simple tasks
which can be a waste of resource. So
meta adapts uh strategy allocation
dynamically rather than using the same
heavy pipeline for everything. The
alphas are allocation weights for the
six optimization strategies and they
represent how much computational budget
is assigned to each strategy for a given
task. So simple tasks um require minimal
processing can save n around a 90% uh
compute compared to standard AC.
moderate tasks um is more of a balanced
approach um that include AC plus
verification and then complex tasks um
basically heavy test time compute
multiple attempts and memory retrieval.
Um so just to conclude with some results
um and and these are initial results uh
we have observed um around an 8 to 11%
uh improvement on agent benchmarks.
Um we have also observed a six to eight
points improvement on on some domain
specific tasks. um also a 30 to 40%
reduction in compute costs um through
the allocation of um adaptive strategies
um and overall there's um there's more
robustness more consistency
um and you know we can generalize better
we can use the framework across a a
diverse range of of domains so the
conclusion is that um meta can can
orchestrate ates a context compute and
verification and memory and parameter
adaptation and produce a robust uh
self-improvement
um framework for agents.
Um future work will implement uh and
evaluate the full system across uh a a
more diverse range of domains and we'll
continue exploring metalarning and this
will involve also incorporating um
additional strategies as well.
Now I also wanted to touch on um
additional applications of meta that I
think are quite relevant. Um so first
one is um for multimodel AI systems. So
for example deciding when to use vision
versus uh language processing again can
be um a like a a meta adaptive uh
strategy decisioning.
Um also when you have uh compound AI
systems that um require different models
for different stages um and the
complexity is um you know is substantial
uh we can actually um uh in a in a meta
adaptive manner uh select the most
effective uh strategies to to resolve a
task and to end. um also um for human
collaboration um so in other words to
determine when to have a human in the
loop and also for continual learning
systems um where we are balancing
exploration versus exploitation.
Um so the the core takeaway is that
optimization requires a meta layer of
intelligence and and that has to be
trained um and you know um it requires
um a lot of trial and error before it
can actually um perform at the right
level.
In terms of the future direction and
challenges um there are still several
challenges that remain. So the meta
controllers training u may be unstable
um due to sparse rewards and that this
can be mitigated through curriculum
learning. Uh also robust advantage
estimation and um regularization of
entropy.
Also computational overhead from
profiling and multiple uh strategies um
needs to be reduced with efficient
models. Um we can leverage things like
lazy execution, batching and caching.
Um also uh the ver verification uh
cascades can be brittle if all models um
make the same mistake. So we need
diverse models um with confidence
waiting and human oversight um as well
as active learning. uh metalarning loops
require substantial data. Uh synthetic
task uh task generation of policy
learning uh transfer from related
domains and sample efficient algorithms
uh can also help as well. And finally uh
addressing these ch these challenges um
is going to be key to scaling meta and
applying it across um a wide range of
domains.
So that was all from me. Thank you very
much for listening. Um, and yeah, uh,
appreciate you being there. Thank you.